une dizaine de policiers accompagnés par
une équipe cynophile de mâcon sont
intervenus ce jeudi dans ce quartier du
tennis au creusot pour des fouilles dans
les parties communes les caves et pour
des contrôles d'identité au final un
bilan très modeste puisque seuls 100
grammes de cannabis ont été saisis mais
l'essentiel est ailleurs
des fois le but n'est pas enfin le but
est bien sûr de trouver du produit et le
but de déstabiliser de d'affirmer la
présence policière ce secteur est de
rassurer la population et l'ensemble des
habitants qui n'ose pas témoigner par
peur des représailles
mais qu'ils voient ce trafic de cocaïne
et d'héroïne surtout prospéré depuis des
années avec des saisies en constante
augmentation 8 kilos d'héroïne saisis en
2016 avec un record à 20 kilos et demi
en 2018 et déjà cinq kilos et demi saisi
depuis le début de l'année pour le
représentant de l'état dans le secteur
ces saisies sont encourageantes mais
elle doit s'accompagner de mesures pour
enrayer la demande notamment par la
vidéoprotection l'entrée d'un collège
dessine on doit pas y voir de dealers ni
les jeunes ni les parents ni personne
même si son corps là qui ne se tachent
parce que c'est interdit doit être caché
si c'est au vu et au su de tout le monde
ce n'est plus interdite et c'est
incompréhensible
marc aubert et le proviseur du lycée
léon blum au creusot
s'il explique ne pas avoir d'impact
visible du trafic à l'intérieur de son
établissement
il reconnaît la présence de guetteur
allait d'abord on voit qu'il ya des
regroupements qui se font en proche de
la gare routière qu'on surveille
attentivement depuis notre entrée
puisqu'elle le surplombe sans qu'on soit
en capacité de détecter finement des
échanges qui caractérise des jeunes gens
qui font l'envié oui on a un petit
groupe l'identifier effectivement au
creusot ce système de vidéoprotection
n'est pour le moment pas à l'ordre du
jour tandis que la ville de torcy doit
être prochainement muni de sa caméra
grâce à un financement à plus de 40% de
l'état